The Joe Rogan Experience you get these
opportunities to like obtain like a
piece of wisdom if you can help it you
know and
um it's always through this the darker
things or the things that are [ __ ]
annoying yeah
and
lately I've been so aware of my lineage
like my family tree and
like my parents my grandparents my
great-grandparents and me and then you
know my my stepdaughter and you know if
we have more kids like where I sit in
this line of generational
um personalities and habits and and
where I see the mistakes and where I
want to make Corrections and it's really
powerful I mean you really have to look
at yourself on the things you don't like
and the things you you like or love and
um
it's a it's a really defining moment
lately like I just feel my again
responsibility to
what is most important
and there there's like I'm so proud to
be from the family I'm from and like the
kind of people and there's so many
things I'm like oh God you know
um
and it feels like a real job to like
heal generational wounds and bad habits
and uh yeah I'm just like
because I if I whatever I can do I want
to give the best things to my children
you know
um
[Laughter]
yeah you're trying to be a good person
but I come from this really long line of
hustlers like my great-grandmother was a
bookie my great-grandfather was a
bootlegger my grandfather was a bookie
and a prisoner of war for two years in
World War II like he was shot down from
an airplane
and like he was a waste Gunner like one
of the most dangerous
jobs you could have
and
he got captured and and like he survived
an 82-day Death March
and and like made it back home to
Cleveland and
like
he married my grandmother who was an
excellent cook and all the money he had
from being a bookie uh they they built
this these restaurants in Cleveland with
my grandma's recipes and it's amazing
like the food's so good and it's like my
family Legacy and
I'm just fascinated by those people and
I I'm I feel really lucky to to be their
granddaughter
yeah that's a that's a that's a
fascinating [ __ ] story it's pretty
wild how did he survive oh man
um how did you survive the crash
he parachuted out so he parachuted it
out and then he gets captured Jesus yeah
he so he never talked about his
experience until he was almost 80.
so he didn't tell like my even my dad
like nobody knew what my grandfather
went through and
he got inspired by somebody to to
finally tell us what he like just tell
his family and he took a year
um doing voice recordings with with his
sister I'm pretty sure it was my Aunt
Rita
um
to tell a story and then like one day
when I was in LA when I was 22 I got
this book in the mail and it was his
like he gave it to our family so we
could all know about what his experience
in World War II was in being a prisoner
of war and I mean it was I mean I mean I
was bawling like makes me emotional just
talking about it like he had finally had
this moment where he felt like it was
okay to tell everybody and it was like
very polite and and sanitized and and
then like by the end of his life he
really wanted to talk about it more and
more in Greater detail but um he carried
one of his friends
um during that 82 day March because I
can't remember where they were moving
them
but it was you know like you walk for 82
days like you can't stop to take a [ __ ]
or pee like you just like he had
dysentery he had lice like he was just
he was filthy and and I like
actually shortly before he died I went
to visit him and and he was telling like
he just wanted to talk and like tell me
these things and
um
you know I remember him saying to me
like and he like looked me in the eye
and he was like you do not know filth
you don't know filth
and just being
like if you stopped they killed you so
you had to keep going and one of his
friends he carried him and and I
remember this old man because my parents
used to send us to Florida where like in
the Summers where my grandparents lived
and we'd spend like two three weeks with
them
and it was awesome but you know Grandpa
was usually uh watching The Sopranos
with his headphones on and like doing
his own thing but you know they were
they were so Italian
um
but his old friend was all like I
remember I think it was I like I don't
want to butcher this but I think it was
his friend uh Mr dragonetti and
like they were friends till they're very
old age and you know
they had this experience together this
horrible experience
um
but like you know not to like Ramble On
unless you want to hear more about it
like I'm just so amazed at that
sacrifice and courage and bravery and
and just Fortune to survive and then to
have a life after that and then I think
about
somebody posting their [ __ ] video
about working too long at Starbucks
and I'm like [ __ ] you I'm sorry [ __ ]
your [ __ ] feelings like
you're gonna be fine you know